all right you can live out your little
mermaid dreams
and become friends with fish stingray
and sharks at a very special aquarium
that has returned to the silverton
casino let's learn more about the
aquarium from his curator
ryan ross welcome to the show ryan ryan
we know there are two fan favorites
you've got the stingray feeding
and the mermaid swim let's start with
the stingrays
how many stingrays do you have in the
tank
well thank you for having me yeah we
have numerous species of stingrays we
have southern stingrays we have cow no
stingrays
we have fiddler stingrays and we have
yellow stingrays and right now right
behind me we have one of our probably
most famous
occupants of the tank is one of our
silverton mermaids
can you tell us a little bit more about
the mermaid show and how that works and
what people can expect
yeah so the the mermaids are in thursday
through sunday
uh so thursday through saturday they
swim from noon
to 8 pm and then sunday they swim from
10 30
to 6 30 p.m oh my gosh and the
stingray feeding shows yeah those are
interactive
and we actually have those every single
day
1 30 and 4 30. when it comes to the
mermaids what kind of training goes into
becoming a mermaid can anyone apply for
the job
notes yeah are there years of training
to be an actual mermaid for you guys
well you can see they make it look
really easy they do have to be scuba
certified
um they make it look very easy but it is
not easy at all because
basically you're taking someone and
you're tying their legs together
and then you're expecting them to swim
around a big tank with sharks and
stingrays
and look graceful while doing it but
they somehow they pull it off
in vegas you can be a showgirl you can
be a mermaid you can do it all here in
las vegas
now i understand they're speaking of
vegas 21 plus after the show there's a
lounge
with the mermaids can you tell us about
that
yes off to my left over here is the
mermaid lounge
definitely come down for a drink we have
live
music right now friday and saturday
night so it's it's definitely a fun
place to hang out and have an adult
beverage
how much is awesome how many fish are in
that tank do you know a fan how many
fish
and how many different species of fish
in that tank that's going to be a big
number
yeah so we have almost 2 000 fish in the
aquarium
and we have over 100 different species
so
there's a lot of different interaction
with these animals and it keeps us very
busy
i'm sure so tell everybody how they can
come down and visit and enjoy themselves
yeah so we have like i said a lot going
on we have the mermaid lounge
we have uh the mermaids thursday through
sunday the interactive feeding shows are
again
every day at 1 30 and 4 30 and be sure
and check back at our website
because soon we're going to have a
mermaid school
so i'll take you around to the front of
the we're kind of in the back of the
aquarium oh ryan we're we're running out
of we're running out of time ryan we got
to come back for a tour yeah
that's the tease that's the ultimate
tease we're all going to come down and
see you and learn about the mermaid
school ryan thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it
by the way yeah you can't beat that
seriously that's awesome over there well